to
our um
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology research
conference
um i um
have um
known her for a number of years and
actually even before i knew her
personally um i knew of her by her
famous cartoon which you see on the
bottom of the slide
to the right and those of you who have
taken my introductory informatics course
have seen this cartoon
which was uh published in the medical
journal jam in 2012 um highlighting um
some of the challenges that um our great
informatics applications namely the
electronic health record have have done
with the physician um
with his back his his head hunched over
the computer his back um to a child and
her family
um
anyways uh uh several years later i i
got to know dr tall she he reached out
to me to be part of the scientific
program committee for a conference she
was putting together called the patient
and the practitioner in the age of
technology promoting healing
relationships and really kind of tried
to bring together
um
informatics geeks like us with people
who are very concerned about um the
patient clinician interaction
and and so forth and um the first
conference actually took place a year
before the pandemic in 2019 in
providence rhode island um the
conference actually continued through
the pandemic we had a virtual conference
and and now we're hopefully having the
third iteration
back in person uh later this year um so
as i said um
her slides i'll go ahead and post the
link in the chat again are here um so dr
toll is a professor of
internal medicine and pediatrics at
brown university school of medicine
and she um
in addition to a clinician is an
academic and and has really been a
leader in this area of
trying to maintain uh
patient physician
uh relationships and interaction in in
our age of technology that can sometimes
undermine that so she's gonna talk about
the conference and what we've learned
particularly the virtual one that took
place this past year
looking at the
issue from a variety of perspectives
patients practitioners
informaticians educators ethicists and
so forth
academically dr told did her
undergraduate work at harvard university
and went to medical school
at the university of rochester
and did her
residency at combined residency and
internal medicine and pediatrics so i
won't take up any more of her time
and i'm looking forward looking forward
to hearing her talk and hopefully some
um dialogue that can take place after
she finishes speaking so go ahead betsy
so thank you so much for this invitation
and that warm welcome
it's great to be here from rhode island
where we're trying to find warm weather
but haven't quite yet
next slide please
it's not advancing
let me try this again
is it possible for us to pull up the
link
in google
in the drive
oh yeah that's uh
sorry
share
okay
from beginning
can everyone see it yeah we we see the
slides
um i am not seeing it now hang on a
second
okay dedication okay
i'm sorry now i can't i can't see it as
the problem so
there we go okay
so um
that is actually not the correct set of
slides but that's fine we'll proceed
with this okay okay
yes
are you able to advance it lynn
are you seeing it it's advancing
here
it's not advancing on the
no
okay
i'm happy to speak extemporaneously if
you like i'm a big fan of radio
and uh
we can try for
a radio con we could try it with my
computer i've got the
i will forward it to you billy i have it
i i have it i clicked on the link let me
just try
okay
um
so to get started i know all of us are
very uh distracted by the events in
eastern europe and i wanted to dedicate
this talk to the brave
uh people of ukraine
um
and i've included one of the things
that's very sad about this time is how
often ukraine has been in the throes of
this kind of
despotism and i included a picture of my
own ancestors who fled from keefe in
1906
before the czar's armies came
the slides advancing for you all
yes they are
okay great only problem is i can't see
them
really not in the webex window
i am in the webex window
so here we go okay great i can see it
now okay
so next slide please
next slide
please
so i do have some disclosures about
salary support i received from the
physicians foundation and those who've
helped to fund the conference the next
slide please
so our objectives today are to share
learning from a
2020-2021 virtual conference series as
dr hirsch mentioned
that i hope will help you be able to
describe some new paradigms of clinical
care that use hit to support patient
practitioner relationships to stay some
specific interventions that can improve
hit access for underserved and
marginalized populations and explain
principles that increase the success of
human centered design and finally some
specific steps that we can take to
protect patient privacy in the age of
big data but first some background next
slide please
i first became interested in this
subject on september 14 2009 which was
the day that my university clinic
converted to the electronic health
record
before that date i would have told you i
have a people job but after that date i
would have said i had a computer job it
was as though a bomb had fallen into our
professional lives next slide please
pretty soon i was like dr jones getting
up at 6 30 in the morning to pre-round
on my patients
seeing patients across the day
taking a brief break at dinner
and then back on the computer at night
until bedtime
completing 24 visits 16 hours on the
computer and more than 2500 clicks
next slide please
pretty soon our research and could you
please go through the animations on this
pretty soon our research showed that
face-to-face time with patients
and computer time were in a ratio of one
hour face to face for every two hours of
computer time
much of this was after hours in our
pajamas so called pajama time next slide
please
please until the pajamas thank you next
slide please
it was hard not to notice the same thing
in human relationships at work
whereas we used to talk to our
colleagues directly now we were
ping-ponging messages through the
computer and our trainees were sent
spending far more time glued to their
computers than they were
at the bedsides of their patients next
please
i felt i was living in a greek myth
would it be sisyphus rolling up the rock
of documentation every day only to have
it roll back down with the frustration
that most of what i was writing was for
billing and administration not clinical
care or would it be the hydra cutting
one message off of my electronic inbox
only to find one more had appeared next
please
before the ehr i would have said that in
a room with a patient my brain and my
heart were both connected to the patient
in front of me next please but
afterwards i felt like i was in a
constant tug of war with my brain and
heart wanting to be connected with my
patient but an alternative loop going
into the computer orders referrals
prescriptions and so forth
it was next please it was almost as
though i was computering while doctoring
which like texting while driving causes
increased accidents decreased attention
and oh by the way next please it's
illegal
next please
about this time my husband came home
from the pediatric clinic where he was
working and he said
you should see the picture that tom
murphy's pain
little patient drew of him
now tom is one of our best residents
ever he had been in the navy before he
became a pediatric resident and he'd
served on an aircraft carrier as the
sole medical officer for three years and
then he started all over again as an
intern and he was kind and humble and
able and on task
but in this picture um his little
patient and her family are sitting at
the end of the bed cheerfully
interacting while dr murphy is totally
focused on his computer
next please
it was hard not to think of this famous
painting of the doctor by luke fields
from late 19th century showing a doctor
sitting at the bedside of a dying child
the parents in the background
next please
only
luke fields doctor is paying attention
to his patient while ag's doctor is
paying attention to his computer next
please
when i saw that picture i said there's
the problem right there even a child can
see it i want to find a way for
a lot of people to see this picture
so i reached out to dr murphy and asked
if he'd be willing to let me write an
essay about this picture and he
graciously agreed and to make a long
story short the cost of technology was
published in 2012. now for this first
time author that was super exciting but
what happened next was even more
exciting next please
people started writing in
they wrote in from doctors nurses mental
health professionals lawyers all
decrying the arrival of the computer in
their professional lives and saying that
it was stealing their attention away
from their patients where they wanted to
be and their jobs had changed and no
longer fit and they had no idea what to
do it seemed to have really struck a
nerve
now there are a few dissenters
and one of those next was an israeli
physician next named shmuel rice next
please
um who had been on the computer for 25
years and loved it and he wrote to me
and he said it's not the computer it's
that you have to learn how to use it in
clinical care
it turned out that shmuel had a long
relationship with brown university and
he came over periodically to work with
his colleagues in family medicine and we
got to know each other and became
friends and he admitted to this long
time dream to have an international
conference on the subject of how the
computer had affected the relationship
between patients and practitioners
next please
next please so to make a long story
short next please
we um came together in
2017
not just physicians
but also patients nurses mental health
professionals hit designers
institutional leaders government
officials educators and researchers
including dr hirsch representing ohsu
and serving on the scientific committee
and one of the big highlights was tom
murphy coming back next please and next
please
to talk about what he had learned from
his patient and her picture
next please
since then we published a consensus
statement in 2019 and we were working on
a live conference in 2020 when the covet
bomb fell
and as the worldwide um health care
system pivoted to telehealth
our conference pivoted to a virtual
series next please
um the series is online if anybody's
interested free of charge through the
cme office at brown next please
the world into which
our kovid
19 bomb fell was very different from the
world into which our 2009 ehr bomb had
fallen next please
we were way more technologically savvy
we were texting and shopping online and
summoning our virtual
assistants and
face timing our kids and so when this
arrived
we in the medical world next please
and next please
were very used to working for example
here's a medical student working not
just off the schedule on the wall but
also for other devices and next please
her apple watch
so we were ready
next please
so once again we assembled a group of
people from all over the united states
with dr hirsch again serving on the
scientific committee and representing
ohsu um and seven other countries again
all kinds of uh people coming from all
kinds of perspectives
next please
we looked at eight themes and things had
changed from our first conference i
would say at the first conference we
spent a lot of time complaining
and but we also spent a time a lot of
time listening to folks from around the
world and we learned that
people around the world were having a
very different experience with their
ehrs where theirs had been designed for
clinical care and the american ones had
been designed for billing and
administration
and um we also began to think of
solutions and now by 2021 particularly
in the pandemic solutions were coming
fast and furiously so it was much more
of a way of using hit to support human
relationships and these are our eight
themes which we're going to look at
today next please
so we learned that relationships matter
more than ever and yet they are changing
next please
so what happens
what is the patient practitioner
relationship and why does it matter
so when a practitioner creates time and
space and brings curiosity and suspends
judgment and offers full attention
that's eye contact listening awareness
of emotions and non-verbals and bears
witness to and sometimes helps to birth
patients stories and then adds the power
of human touch
next please twice
that creates a human connection and
trust
then add to that knowledge and technical
skill next please twice
this offers healing for both and emerges
from a kind of improvisation this
patient this problem this day
now what do we mean by healing for both
so i think if you talk to most people
who are healthcare practitioners um they
probably did pretty well in school but
there may have been some other areas
that were tough perhaps they were a
little socially awkward or not as
attractive or popular or athletic as
other people and yet somewhere deep
inside themselves they had a sense that
they knew how to help people or they
wanted to learn how to do this
next please
it could be as the timeless
physician we saw earlier in the painting
next
or playing with some kids as a
pediatrician
or
getting together next please or getting
together with an elder
next
or
serving in an underserved part of the
world next or being in a high-tech
setting like the or or the
interventional radiology suite but in
every sense it was the feeling of being
able to connect with somebody to get
them to feel better that gave the
practitioner sense of worth and sense of
loving themselves and that is a kind of
healing so it's too it's bi-directional
next please
when i finished my training it was
pretty easy to do that as part of our
general work i would listen to my
patient i would observe and use past
medical history think about this patient
their exam put my learning together some
common sense think about the uh the
emotions in the room and i often imagine
that i had these threads coming into my
brain that were being woven together to
help create a plan for my patient next
however
when i started practicing in the early
1990s and i was trying to do this
threads and braid thing
i felt like little drawers were starting
to open up in my brain
one was called formularies and it held
information about which drug was covered
by which insurance company and another
was called specialists and it had the
names of specialists that were covered
by certain insurance companies there
were drawers overflowing with
with billing codes and and information
about documentation and i often felt
that patient care was being pushed into
a little drawer about the size of a
pistachio nut
next please
so when the ehr joined this with this
complex formularies and windows and
clicks it almost felt like now it was
braids and
threads and braids and apothecary
drawers and an annex had opened my brain
to manage the ehr and it was almost
impossible to focus on what the day's
work was exhausting next please
so over the past generation i think we
could say that healthcare in the united
states has moved from
relationship-based care towards
transactional care with the growth of
corporate and insurance oversight
administrative and regulatory
responsibilities and the presence of the
ehr including all of its challenges and
strengths
this has often left patients feeling
disconnected and unattended to and
practitioners feeling moral distress
depersonalization and burnout i'm sure
some of you have had the experience of
being in an office with a practitioner
who is paying attention to the computer
and not you
next please
but we've learned that patients and
families and actually practitioners too
want trusting relationships with their
healthcare team and their patients but
they also want hit they want access to
records patient portals help manage
chronic conditions who wants to take
care of a patient without being able to
look at old labs or old test results
they want it for communication with the
health care team and for education but
we all want user-friendly technology
like in the rest of our lives and
interoperability and merging the best of
old and new
next please
so team-based care forms one new
paradigm for these kinds of
relationships when we redesign the job
descriptions in the office or the or to
maximize people's level of training and
we redesign space so that the team can
be co-located again communicating
face-to-face instead of ping-ponging
through the computer this streamlines
workflow and the team members get to
know each other well in their routines
and they can work together to manage the
inbox close care gaps like who's missing
a mammogram or a colonoscopy and oversee
population health is all of you folks
too
the second person can start the visit
can do the documentation and can help
with after visit care and also knows the
patient well
this increases satisfaction on
everybody's part decreases that pajama
time and burnout and team-based care has
been successfully implemented in
training clinics preparing future
clinicians so a patient feels i have my
doctor back not focused on the computer
focused on me and i'm glad there's
somebody else in the office who also
knows me well
the doc says my pajama time is way down
and the nurse or team coordinator feels
like she has a much more interesting and
fun job
next please
covet 19 has certainly reinforced the
importance of relationship skills
because it's been so hard to communicate
with this dangerous disease particularly
early on and how important it's been
seen that clear regular communication
can take place both within the team and
with patients and families who can't be
on the scene when patients are
hospitalized
we've found how important listening and
eye contact are especially because
they're so hard to do with masks and
personal protective equipment
we've also had much less physical
presence and exam as teams particularly
early on rushed in and out of patient
rooms so they themselves would not get
sick and patients have really missed
that
but technology has been a phenomenal
bridge vis video greater than telephone
or text and all of these are harder if
there's not already an existing trusting
relationship next please
so we could probably say over the past
20 years that relationships have changed
from a dyad of patient and physician
where the doctor has the knowledge the
training and facilitates the agenda
next
to one in which our patients have become
also describing the problem um and using
their own knowledge and agenda setting
skills next
to a triad of the patient the doctor and
the computer and by that we also mean
the healthcare team
the family the healthcare team and the
ehr
into a triangular configuration where
all three are working together for the
outcome next please
and now we are moving into a four-way
relationship with a i next please
and the hope is that if ai can offer
knowledge and decision support
that this can leave room for the
practitioner to get back towards the
patient the psychosocial aspects of the
visit and strengthen those relationships
next please
so a couple of examples um we heard from
dr chris uh
pearce who's an informaticist in
melbourne australia
who now is launching a dashboard of
health factors
to 2000 practices in australia
where an ehr can predict hospitalization
that actually is a little bit high it's
between 75 and 80 percent accuracy about
whether a patient will end up in the er
in the next month using things like what
conditions does this patient have what
medications are they on how old are they
how much do they weigh what's their
blood pressure today what do we know
about their psychosocial life and habits
um there's also a new uh cough a
smartphone into which one can cough
which diagnoses pneumonia as accurately
actually pneumonia croup and asthma with
an accuracy equal to a physician plus an
x-ray
and at uh stanford dr naropsha shared um
information about how um patients are
entering their symptoms into a
smartphone app
which is connected to allergens and
weather and pollution data which allows
them to avoid high allergen areas
decrease med use and has given a lot
more information about
patients with allergies finding for
example that headache is a more
consistent symptom of people having
allergic symptoms
and that pollution causes more allergies
allergic symptoms than allergens
themselves
um they're also using myasthenia gravis
patients entering clinical data taking
selfies of their eyes and speaking into
the smartphone
and the very subtle changes in muscle
strength can be picked up more easily by
the smartphone app
and the audio app
and help people figure out when a flare
is coming next please
next we looked at disparities um this
second pandemic that has plagued us next
please
and we heard about um from a visionary
leader speaking about how to improve
society's health this will require
addressing structural racism throughout
society and medical institutions
offering equal access to technology hit
education and the pandemic has
highlighted all of this next
the foundation for this is trusting
relationships and trusting institutions
next
and that trust comes from respect and
non-judgment seeing every patient as a
unique human being shaped by many forces
every one of which impacts health
and allows us to deliver the best care
to each patient next
we heard about safety net populations
where access to digital devices and
broadband is a huge issue a quarter of
our rural and a third of our tribal
areas have limited or no internet as
we've seen as kids have tried to engage
in online schooling
language and culture is so important to
communication and equity if you want to
deliver good health care patients need
and and practitioners need access to
qualified interpreters and everyone
needs education about using this
technology patients families and proxies
people who like group homes or health
care providers in the home who need um
to be able to help get on these systems
research is another area
dr as we mentioned before the smartphone
can be used as a research research tool
and the all of us project is now seeking
a million potential research subjects
who actually reflect the diversity of
the u.s population as you all know there
are many cultural biases in ai
algorithms and so forth next
people with disabilities were addressed
as well um they too deserve quality care
and support of technology when we design
for people with differences it helps us
all for example sidewalk cuts help not
only someone using a wheelchair but also
someone pushing a stroller or a walker
and when we have multiple access points
into hi2 systems people who may have
differences for example someone with
autism and social challenges and sensory
issues who prefers portal messaging to
phone conversations has a way to
communicate next please
so too in mental health
the move to telehealth has shown that we
can decrease barriers to accessing
mental health like access to quality
care transportation child care social
anxiety and stigma show rates have
improved and we have the same or
improved clinical outcomes
one researcher who is working on a
project of using mindfulness
interventions to treat um
patients who are pregnant with
hypertension found that it was much more
convenient for her study subjects to
participate in phone surveys and in fact
she was able to recruit a more diverse
group of participants next please
so too in the developing world
well-designed ehrs can improve
healthcare delivery if you have an easy
intuitive
ehr it can be used by a community health
worker or a medical assistant a nurse
not just physicians and many people can
become involved in keeping track of hiv
or tuberculosis patients
innovation can also bring hit to
underserved communities by adding it to
existing platforms like banking or
rideshare apps next please
next we looked at designing
human-centered hit naturally steve jobs
was not at our conference but wouldn't
we all like hit that worked as smoothly
as apple technology next
please but it's a challenge cumbersome
ehr and hit design plus burdensome work
expectations keep patients from
practitioners next please
we thought we talked about usability and
heard from a cancer patient who had is
also a digital designer there is jay on
the left at sloan kettering memorial in
new york doing his 14 laps around the
nursing station every day he has his
unicorn horn and his unicorn slippers
that his daughters gave him
and as he was trying to get some
exercise during his hospitalization he
was just dumbfounded by how much time
nurses and doctors were spending at
their computers and how little time they
were actually spending with their
patients so he developed a tool called
ux to streamline usability um involving
all users and stakeholders
he found that patients and nurses have
lots of fantastic input as well as docs
and should be compensated for this came
up with eight categories and 42 measures
to actually evaluate a piece of hit next
please
next we heard from some human factors
engineers about the basic principles of
human centered design again we need to
involve all users at every stage
so we can understand the context and the
purpose of a device or a piece of
software and we go through cycles of
invention trial and modification and we
always need to consider and monitor for
unintended consequences which i gather
is this topic of special interest in
your department
again universal design helps all users
next
please
next we looked at advancing patient
empowerment to use this kind of
technology whether that's at home in a
healthcare visit or online say using
chat bots next
please we heard from liz salmi who is
again a cancer patient who's become very
involved in the hit world and she
advocates for full participation in the
healthcare team and has become closely
allied with the open notes project to
allow patients to access their actual
clinical notes not simply a visit
summaries and she advocates for
accessing all data and medical records
they belong to the patient um and
patients should also begin to contribute
to the chart with biographies or visit
agendas photos videos articles and so
forth a new project is coming out of the
open notes undertaking called our notes
where physicians and patients are
co-creating their notes
she's also using hit to connect patients
who have similar conditions or
experiences through blogging next please
patients want to create biographies
wouldn't it be great if you open the
chart and you hear what the patient
wants to know about you
who you live with
how you like to be treated what makes
you happy next please and wouldn't it be
great if patients could just tell you
some information they want you to know
the minute you log on to their charts
about their boyfriends or their habits
what you can tell their parents next
please
our transgender youth are constantly
frustrated by having to re-explain
themselves every time they encounter the
healthcare system and a new practitioner
wouldn't it be great to have the basic
information when you open the chart next
please
or how about an adopted patient who's
continuously asked about family medical
history when they have no access to that
next please
something as simple as mirrored screens
can help where a patient sees the same
thing as a physician can again create
that triangular relationship where
patient and practitioner have the same
information from the computer in front
of them next please
we learned about the patrol portal which
has just huge potential and some
research success successes excuse me
including decreased time to uh your
kidney transplant if you're on the
portal prompt electronic visits with an
endocrinologist if you're on the portal
fewer ed visits for inflammatory bowel
disease if you can get to your
practitioner and improve monitoring of
cancer drug toxicities but portal
messages need triaging most of them do
not require a physician's attention and
it's important to acknowledge and
compensate care delivered through the
portal fairly next please
we talked about devices whether that's
home monitoring of blood pressure and
glucose or prescribing apps like to
evaluate sleep or to track exercise or
to gather research data as we heard
about we heard an interesting uh project
using the apple watch to help predict
prevent falls in older adults but again
this information needs filtering for the
patient and the practitioner most apps
are currently unregulated and of course
data can fall into the wrong hands next
please
next we look to teaching hit to support
this kind of relationship-based care
that we all want next please
so two of the leaders here are weiwei
lee and lolita al qarashi two docs at
the university of chicago who became
famous for their human level mnemonic
where they helped to give people
concrete skills for best practices of
using a computer in a room with a
patient next please
they also made a movie on the doctor
channel about best and worst practices
next please
and now they're helping to train
patients to use the ehr using
cartoons next please
so here we have a asked to see the
screen doc i'm feeling a bit left out
here may i see what you're typing the
doc says of course i'm sorry let's turn
the screen so you can see your list of
current medications creating that
triangular configuration
next please
be for become involved it says there i'm
still taking that pain medicine but
that's not true i'm not taking it
anymore okay glad we reviewed those
medicines together we can correct that
next please
or call for attention doctor this part's
a bit difficult to discuss could we move
away from the computer now
absolutely please tell me what's on your
mind thanks for listening and they
actually studied this and when patients
were instructed with these cartoons that
they had the right to ask for these
things and could become involved they
felt much more empowered in the visit um
and that was also found from the
direction of the practitioners when they
were studied next please
we heard from shmuel rice who started
all this and his uh a co-a resident
who's working in his small practice of
600 patients in northern israel and they
are seamlessly moving through technology
in their care
not only having patients in the office
but communicating through email sms
texting video participation whether
that's bringing a family member into the
appointment or having the doc jump into
a specialist appointment
they're using telemedicine for example
to manage covet patients and social
media to relay information for example
recall of a medication new safety
information about covenanting
vaccination information and also to re
to address misinformation and recently
schmuel has started blogging uh one of
his early blogs was about creating
advanced directives for end-of-life care
and he's kind of nervous about how his
patients would feel about receiving
information like that but 50 or 60
patients then filled out an advanced
directive and sent them back to him so
it was tremendously effective way to
teach about that next please
of course educating humanistic digital
practitioners whether we're talking
about all the people currently in the
workforce or our future trainees is
going to involve many subjects not only
all medical knowledge but what's
etiquette note writing communication
population health research teaching how
do we use the ehr for all this stuff as
well as the ethical challenges involved
it's a wonderful opportunity for the
young and old to teach each other
got to start early
and you have to engage the c-suite in
this next please
and our learners will need to be
versatile to match people and tasks with
modality so for this patient of this age
with this need should we be face-to-face
should we use telehealth do we text blog
portal apps and we have to be very
careful not to not to get our
practitioners
afflicted with the attention deficit
disorder of hit switching next please
we have to educate our patients to
become full team members whether that's
via a cartoon whether it's teaching them
in the office or whether it's teaching
them how best to use telehealth next
please
next we looked at promoting wellness and
clinical care certainly has was a huge
issue before the pandemic and has become
almost another epidemic of epidemic
proportions during the pandemic
next please
so there's hope what we've seen is that
from rapid change and the epidemic of
burnout in the u.s before covet 19
um we know that excellent health care
requires a healthy workforce
that's now part of the quadruple aim and
it's also good business practice you
can't run a business where half your
employees are burned out
so institutions need to commit to
promoting those human relationships that
we all need and clinician wellness to
staffing to creating adequate staffing
and systems to harnessing hit to support
and not interfere with the workforce and
to get ongoing input from the front
lines that's patients and families and
all medical professionals and we need
leaders who are strong enough to hold
themselves accountable to these goals
next please
we asked some broad questions what are
health and wellness anyway for all the
health care we deliver we don't always
have much health or wellness and we
heard from a nurse educator in scotland
who's working on a project with his
hydrocephalus and spina bifida patients
um he's creating a digital dashboard to
help patients figure out what are the
elements that are involved in them
feeling well
is it um
a sense of who they live with this what
their activities are
their medications their treatments what
are the components of putting together
well-being how can they create a
wellness score and use that to help them
work towards positive change next please
and we heard from a nurse educator in
the united kingdom
about health in our society and
and and thinking about shifting our
current paradigm of reacting to illness
to proactively promoting health
how best can we use technology to to
work towards this goal and what would a
healthy home or school or business or
city look like anyway
next please
we heard how improving the ehr
experience can improve clinician
wellness at the university of virginia
the it department has been using epic
data to analyze a
doctor's workflow and working
individually with them to create to help
them with efficiency decrease their
pajama time and their stress next please
and we heard about an interesting um
project in rhode island where
every two years all docs in rhode island
have to fill out an hit survey
under their license number and that was
linked to their actual epic user data to
see which kinds of interventions might
which which uh shortcuts in epic are
actually helping and which are driving
burnout
next please there's a series of three
there one two
three four
five okay
next please
next please um and we also learned how
youtube video modules can be very
effective a way to teach ehr skills just
like it teaches you to change your
breaks or
revarnish a table next please
we also saw how technology can connect
people we heard from a young attending
who during his residency became very
jaded by the marine mentality of of his
the teaching approaches in his um in his
hospital and he got involved in
podcasting and found that when people
were excited about learning and hearing
from people who were kind and warm and
friendly it became joyful again and he
went on to create a pediatric
podcast as well next please
we saw and there's a series of pictures
here uh i think three or four um we saw
how technology can create decrease
loneliness and shame of professional
crises like litigation by helping
connect people through blogging and
podcasting for support and education
about how to go through these traumatic
experiences
and we also
talked about the use of mindfulness
um to help
people in the healthcare system um learn
to manage overload and there's a series
here as well
um so mbat uses senior clinicians not
mindfulness instructors to teach medical
students to use reflection and
meditation to manage stress and
information
emotional technological overload um next
please twice um and this of course can
be delivered in person or remotely
next please
we looked at working with governments
institutions and stakeholders um poor
support in these healing relationships
and
wise use of human capital next please
and we looked at the subject of
telehealth around the world um talking
to practitioners all over the united
states and also uh the united kingdom
and the netherlands
and we learned that the the general
feeling was that it was safe convenient
it connected people at the beginning of
the pandemic and the ease regulations
around getting on to facetime or skype
with your patient made it possible for
people to connect easily with familiar
platforms
when it wasn't possible through the ehr
and it helped people in remote areas or
who couldn't get to the office access
quality care
again it works best when there's already
a trusting relationship between the
patient and the practitioner
and over time both groups wanted human
live connection and many decided they
would wait for live visits which of
course has led to delayed click delayed
care and misdiagnosis that we're dealing
with now everybody agreed that a hybrid
system is the future
we need to compensate people who deliver
that care fairly and of course there are
concerns about teledoc companies who
don't have relationships with patients
coming in for financial gain
privacy and security are important not
only hacking into the health care aspect
of it but we don't want somebody having
a telehealth visit while they're driving
we don't want we want to make sure their
children are safe and we always need to
think could there be an abuser in the
house at the time of the visit
and again telehealth is useless if it
doesn't belong to everyone we need
broadband digital devices interpreting
and education for all next please
finally we looked at the ethical
stewardship of shared data next please
ehrs have generated huge amounts of data
um and population health has great
potential but as you all know bias and
inequity exist
in informatics in a.i and there is that
paradox of the connect interconnectivity
that we desire makes it more and more
concerning that we will lose our privacy
and so we need to consider
confidentiality within the exam room
privacy within the uh the hospital
system itself and security as all of
this goes into the cloud
and we need to ally with our patients to
advocate for their privacy patients have
a timeless need to confide in their
practitioners
so many people come to their dock as the
person who knows their family who knows
them and to whom they tell their deepest
darkest secrets and groups have unique
needs teens don't want the parents to
know stuff parents don't want their kids
to know stuff people with mental illness
don't want anybody to know about it and
many others so we have to protect
patients
with education about limits for example
hipaa doesn't apply to any data that's
been downloaded from a computer the
cures act of 2021 is helping both to
cause more of a problem and to decrease
the problem but we need clarity about
how health data are being used
within the system healthcare system but
also as patients load more and more of
it into applications on smartphones and
obviously big tech and privacy including
health records is under close scrutiny
by the united states press and citizenry
around the country
next please
so
when our system converted to epic in
2015 there was a big hoopla about the
very first patient who was born into the
system thereafter i believe his name was
cameron this is not his picture
but um everyone was so excited that
cameron's entire life would be in epic
and i can tell you that as a primary
care physician i felt sorry for cameron
and i found myself sort of flashing
through his potential lifespan thinking
about the things every patient hopes
nobody except their physician will ever
hear about um at age 13 it could be
embarrassing teen questions it could be
an episode of chlamydia or a period of
you know heavy substance use and all of
our patients and ourselves have gone
through moments like this that have
tremendous personal professional and
political implications next please if
they are outed on social media and so
next please i feel very strongly that
those people who are creating electronic
health records need to find a way to
have a dumb old-fashioned word document
where a patient may be designed like an
old-fashioned medical history where
patients and practitioners can put in
this private data which is highly
relevant medically but is nobody else's
business and can never be faxed or
shared with anybody else
next please
um and of course i'm sure you're all
familiar with shashana zuboff's book um
looking at the money involved in patient
data whether in applications or other
settings on the internet um hugely
eye-opening um and hugely important to
understand how important it is for us to
figure out how to regulate this stuff
wisely next please so to summarize um we
are involved in the art of medicine next
please
um which asks us to come together to
give full attention to patients and the
laying on of hands next please and to
create those relationships that are so
rewarding for both people for all people
who participate in them
next please but at the same time we are
tasked with science next please whether
that's using the latest technology to
learn new ways to communicate with our
patients or next please has given us
within incredibly short time of
effective vaccinations against this
covin-19 bug antivirals and other
treatments next please but has also
given us the technology to spread fake
facts next please and miss information
and disinformation so it's our job to
sort through all this so that we can
bring together the best of both
next please
so i thank you
and i'm certainly happy to entertain
questions and comments um can i see you
go back for a second if anybody's
interested in um
the link um to these these five programs
they're available through cme at brown
we are on to we hope a live conference
next october um and we've just um closed
our submissions but if any of you have a
project that you would be interested in
presenting at this uh dr hirsch is on
the scientific committee and you can
connect with me and we'd be delighted to
welcome you into a really really fun uh
fold of people thank you for your
attention and time
great thank you um
yeah i don't have any special
connections but um that we um we are
happy to um consider other
um
uh submissions that come in after the
deadline um
well great um thank you um for this talk
which um went very well despite the
um technical limitations and as one who
participated in this process i think
this is a phenomenal
summary of the issues that came up in
the conference and also the issues that
come up in the practice of informatics
so
i'm going to um
just open up the floor people can
either type questions into the chat
or they can unmute themselves
and just speak up and if you do that to
maybe turn on your video so we can see
you
so
any questions from the audience
welcome comments as well
yes comments too
well maybe i will kick it off uh myself
um so um as you know betsy i'm probably
about half of uh the uh folks in
attendance here are
uh individuals who are studying uh to
become
informaticians and um um hopefully they
have found this helpful some of them are
clinicians others of them are not um
what what advice would you give to
someone who's um you know studying the
uh technical side of things the
technology making it work right um
what advice would you give them as
they're going through their studies to
make sure that they
remember
some of the issues that you've brought
up
well one of the wonderful things um
about
everybody trying to do anything in
healthcare is that you're also patients
so you have also seen this stuff playing
out in full color in your own visits
with your own practitioners so
um i think it's important to watch um
how you feel uh as you're being treated
um with somebody who's using hit to
support the visit and somebody who's
like
either back is to you they're typing
they're not paying attention to you um
so that's one piece of advice i think
the second is also to remember just
people who go into healthcare want human
relationships and so we have to really
work hard to try to protect and promote
those because it's better health care
if you're not paying 100 attention to
your patient you miss a lot of subtle
clues and the patient doesn't feel paid
attention to and so they won't tell you
the real stuff so that leads to a lot of
excessive testing and misdiagnosis and
stuff and the third is i think to engage
in that cycle of
understand the context something's going
to be used in engage all the
stakeholders at every stage of the game
compensate them so they're interested in
participating
um and think about the unintended
consequences of things um i i saw dr
ash's name kobaya i believe
she's
unintended consequences here so um i
can't see the chat but maybe anyway
i'll read the questions from the chat
and she actually
has one um in the chat um one of the
areas that she's become very interested
lately in her research is is the use of
scribes medical scribes um so her
question is was there any discussion
about the use of medical scribes at the
conference and was it in favor or
against
so again i think um
we did talk about the scribes at both
conferences uh in 2017 and then again
last year um i think the feeling is
again it has to do with um people
getting used to working together
so if your scot scribe falls out of the
sky and is working with you and tomorrow
you have a different one the next day
you have a different one it's very hard
um
to train that person to write
effectively um so um however i know some
people for example are working with a
single scribe who happens to be a
physician in mumbai
who's you know on a smartphone in the in
the physician's pocket
um who is a physician listening to this
office to this visit and creating a
physician type of note which is highly
meaningful and done by the end of the
visit so i think you have everything
from you know an undergraduate college
student who wants to go to medical
school who's working say at a free
clinic and honestly doesn't know medical
terminology yet to a doctor who's
moonlighting and subscribe so i think
again it's developing a relationship
with that person it's developing a
workflow with that person it's having an
understanding of language you talk about
how to organize the visit how to
organize the notes so i think it's
that's the value of using team a team
person rather than a scribe because that
team person knows the patient knows the
visit knows the context knows the
history so
great
um and i'll move on to the next uh
question and we'll we'll go a few
minutes over since we um
um
got a little bit of a late start if
people need to leave they can just drop
off um but um i want to make sure
we answer every question or get every
discussion point gets brought up so from
annette garner um so timely i teach in
the rn bs program
in the integrative practice practicum
course we are in the middle of a
two-week discussion nursing informatics
through the lens of telehealth this
presentation would be so useful for our
students affirming ideas they are
bringing forward addressing gaps they
are finding in their practice thank you
i think that's more of a comment than a
question but if you have any comments
about that comment that would be great
um yeah i mean i i think again it's um
you know it's so interesting because i
think uh you know nursing is such a
bedside profession you know i think even
more than physician perhaps is the sense
of being with the patient staying with
the patient until they feel better
whatever that means whether it's
emotional or physical or both
um so how does we how do we think about
doing that on telehealth
and it's been so fascinating in the
mental health world to see
so many people
pivoting to telehealth because of the
dangers of covet early on but being con
and which is you know in a profession
that really depends on the relationship
where you don't have benefit of physical
exam you have only the relationship in
the room that you create with the
patient and that's such an important
part of why people get better in mental
health um what does it mean that so much
of that has been moved to
telehealth but actually a lot of people
think that patients prefer that they
prefer to talk about their personal
problems in their own home
they feel um it's it's easier to be open
um so i think um it's it's it's a hybrid
world and i think we're going to have to
figure out
which people fit best with which
modality is in which settings and it's
still
playing out i guess is how i would say
and uh she's
and we see a lot of the home obviously
when you visit a home on telehealth and
when your patient visits your home i
tell health you get a lot of information
about each other you know sometimes it
could be the ceiling fan but sometimes
it could be
you know chaos in the home order in the
home pets children you get a feeling for
how things are going and so that's very
valuable information in many cases
yeah and i you know and i also think
that you know we talk a lot about
physician burnout and how the impact on
um
of on of the ehr on physicians but
nurses bear just as much if not more
impact of of the ehr and and probably um
don't um have the same attention that
that they deserve in how
the issues that that they deal with that
they end up to
putting a ton of information in
that no one may ever look at
or um you know just being bogged down
with with the ehr
yeah
yeah i mean i think there's so much hope
for
um
virtual assistants
and natural language processing so you
know why couldn't we ask siri
hey siri find me the last cbc you know
and you guys have probably seen that
famous movie about iris the
the ehr created by crico at harvard luke
satos group um
you know where they actually you can say
can you get me the patient's last blood
count what's the patient's wife's name
you know and when was the last
colonoscopy and in real time the
computer participates as a third
conversationalist and then creates the
note through that and i think that's
probably where we're heading and we're
in this kind of like
i don't know the glue age of medicine
where everything is just so slow and
difficult and split up but i think we're
we have the technology in other parts of
our life that if it were used in
medicine would make it much easier just
to speak through these things and not to
be clicking and searching all these
different windows
yeah it wasn't too long ago we were
talking about you know let's get the fax
machine out of healthcare
so we've kind of we've somewhat caught
up
we've mostly digitized healthcare but
but we still don't have the kind of um
frictionless technology that we have in
in other areas of our lives so yeah
hopefully that will change and maybe
some of the uh folks here will will be
the leaders in that regard
well good i don't um i don't see any
more um questions in the chat and no
one's um speaking up so um once again i
want to thank you maybe someday we'll
actually have have you out here live in
in person but uh one one upside to the
pandemic for us has been that we have
had a lot more um uh speakers from
outside the university
and so um
um it's been great to have you give this
talk and um i hope everyone has a great
day and thanks again betsy thank you so
much for the invitation and it's been
pleasure meeting you all remotely take
care have a good